our next guest had her breakout role as
eeko in the Disney plus series Hawkeye I
love Hawkeye a few years ago um now
she's got her own series it's named
after her character echko and you can
also see it on Disney plus say hello to
alaa Cox
[Applause]
[Music]
everybody
so everybody let's let's welcome Ashley
this is a Loa interpreter welcome Ashley
as
well this is common I'm going to
introduce you to Common nice to meet you
yeah great to meet you great to meet you
blessings so you're a new mama right so
how's that like yes I'm a new mom to a
three-month-old son he just became three
months old a few days ago oh my gosh
he's growing so fast I can't believe it
that time does actually fly I truly
believe that quote now I absolutely are
you
tired at first yes he probably woke me
up four or five times a night in the
beginning but now he's gotten better
with sleeping so I am very fortunate you
know I don't want to jinx it now though
we're going to yeah here you go that's
not wood there we go yeah I was like no
no don't jinx it so motherhood what do
you feel like has surprised you did you
always want to be a
mother I've always wanted to be a mom I
always wanted many many kids but now
with my career I think I'm might keep it
to one or two yeah solid
move that's what I say so how do you go
you gring Wisconson how does one go from
going over Wisconsin to all of a sudden
on
Hawkeye my gosh I get this question a
lot but it's just a cool story that I
have
um I never had acting on my radar before
a friend of mine said me sent me the
call casting for a deaf indigenous woman
in their 20s
and at first I was apprehensive but then
I got the same text from two other
friends and I thought there's no way I'm
going to get it because her character
Maya does not have an amputated leg so I
thought there's no way they would hire
me and three months later I auditioned
got the role and here we are now I was
so
surprised it's an amazing Story how do
you feel like this role has you know an
impact with the indigenous communities
and also anybody wanting to achieve this
dream that has prosthetic that maybe
feel like they won't get hired for that
I mean you're representing so many
people right
now it feels like a huge honor to be
able to represent all these
underrepresented
communities I want kids to be able to
see themselves and feel worthy we
deserve this space in this moment I am
so happy Hollywood is making these
changes and accommodations for us it's a
great time to live right now absolutely
I I love that positive outlook on it too
so what what do you feel like common
your you're an actor you do all the
things you win all the awards what do
you feel like um you've done that has
had a huge social impact obviously
Glory well yeah I mean I think being a
part of um Glory was to the the film CMA
it really was just bigger than John and
I or Ava duven I was we we all
collectively put our hearts and souls
into it but it became something that was
more of a movement and and it raised the
Consciousness um and I I always look at
those Awards is like these are things
that allow me to do more work do more do
more of the work so I'm grateful for
them I'm very grateful and I and I
receive them but I feel like anytime I
get one I got to do more like for the
people that's how I feel yeah well cuz
you have the the chance not everybody
gets that opportunity so explain for
everybody that hasn't seen ha Hawkeye
like explain you know Ekko and her
powers I love Ekko she's such a cool
character she's deaf indigenous of
course and an ampute we added that in I
always love that we can add that to my
identity um but she's strong she's Brave
she's fearless she's a competitor she
and her powers they are C culturally
related with each other so she uses her
powers from her ancestors it's so crazy
to see myself on the screen behind me so
sorry about that but beco was a very
cool person I mean you look badass I'd
be like that's me that's me I did that
well everybody here is a look at aaox
and
eeko
that one kick you held up there and then
said no that was yeah oh my God go can
you imagine the pain my leg is metal if
I hit somebody in the face that would be
so painful but my older brother when he
was 16 we are 16 months apart I would
take off my leg and literally hit him
with it
yeah incredible that was amazing what
she did oh my gosh oh gosh thank you so
much I appreciate that oh man if I was
ever going to be a Marvel some I was an
actor I'd be like which one is like
chill which one has the power of chill
like it doesn't have to do all that um
well everybody Echo dreams on Disney
plus be sure to check it
[Music]
[Applause]
out thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home